we felt a little banned I I certainly I
did about leaving the university I
thought very interesting work on
artificial intelligence was really on
the verge of taking place and
symbolically proving programs were
correct ironically now you know it's
taken a long time the rate of progress
which is hard to make numeric and both
those areas has been quite modest I mean
we haven't come backwards or anything
but AI is turned out to be a tougher
problem which is fascinating so we
thought we'd miss being more at the
center of those now through at least
funding Microsoft research we get to
have some a level of involvement in that
one of Paul's ideas was to build a 360
Emulator that was the dominant Mainframe
of the time used bit slice architecture
to just you know blow away the pricing
on Mainframe Computing but we decided
that was kind of boring uh compared to
personal opinion a company came along
about five years later but we didn't
have anything even close to hey let's
build the computer that we want to use
that we want to have as a tool for our
own messing around and communication and
creativity that kind of got at the
center of our thinking even from the
early days Bill Gates saved my business
he doesn't know it but when I meet him
when I shake his hand I'll tell him the
impact that he had on a young 19 year
old Evan Carmichael who wanted to quit
on his company because he felt like he
wasn't good enough to keep going in my
first business I had a software company
it was biotech software I felt wholly
unprepared I'm 19 years old I don't know
much about software I I suck at science
it was my worst subject growing up in
school and now I'm I'm running a
scientific software company and
in that first year
I had a giant range of emotions at the
beginning you're excited it's like yeah
I get to do this thing oh my gosh it's
so excited I turned down my dream job to
be able to do this instead of flying
around the world and making six figures
and doing the investment banking that I
thought I wanted and my friends wanted
here I was saying no I'm gonna do my own
business yeah let's go and then pretty
quickly you realize oh my gosh this is
so much harder than I thought Can it can
any of you guys relate you know have you
gone through that Journey yourself and
um I isolated myself I felt bad talking
to my friends about it that I wasn't
having success because I turned down the
jobs that they wanted and when they
wanted to go hang out
I had to pick one thing per month that I
could do because 25 for pizza and beer
you know was was too much for me to pick
one thing per month that I could do and
I would tell them that I was just living
the entrepreneur life you know I'm
hustling I'm grinding but really I was
isolated alone and had no self-belief or
self-confidence because I was working
every day
and just not seen any results
so where does Bill Gates step in you
know I still haven't met him yet but on
the on the worst day of my life when I
quit on my business partner
I reminded myself that I can't quit yet
that I would live in regret if I quit
now and that somebody else must have
figured this out before and the the
first person I thought of was Bill Gates
because at the time Microsoft was the
biggest software company in the world I
had a software company maybe I could
learn from him that was as simple as it
got it was out of a move of desperation
feeling like I tried everything else and
nothing was working so maybe I could
learn something from Bill Gates
and I researched this story not how does
Bill Gates make an extra million dollars
you know now but how do they start zero
to one how did he do that because I
wanted to do something similar
and I found out he did it through
Partnerships
so their big deal Microsoft's big deal
came when they partnered with IBM and
IBM was the biggest computer
manufacturer at the time and so every
IBM that was shipped had Microsoft
software on it and that was a deal that
blew up Microsoft turned them into a
huge company
but before they made that deal with IBM
there were still a seven million dollar
company
seven million is nothing compared to
what they became but it was still seven
million more than what I had at the time
so like how did they get to 7 million
that how did it get to 1 million how did
that happen still two Partnerships
they had software and they constantly
partnered with people who had Hardware
they had computers and here's our
software that you can run on your
computer on their very first deal with
the mitz Altair
and so I thought that's interesting how
can I apply that how can I find people
to partner with instead of having me go
off and sell One customer One customer
One customer at a time how can I partner
with somebody who can then introduce me
to tons of customers
and my first deal was with the company
into the UK and we signed an exclusive
arrangement for the UK and they paid an
upfront fee of Thirteen and a half
thousand dollars
and I was so scared and so nervous to
even ask for that because I'm making 300
bucks a month 13 and a half K is
mind-blowing and I was nervous to send
the email like you know what I'm going
to send it we'll just see what happens
I'm gonna trust in the in the Bill Gates
partnership strategy and they said yes
and we closed the deal
and more important than the money that
came in was the hope he's like oh my
gosh momentum you know how it feels when
you maybe you felt that a little bit in
your business just somebody believes in
you a little bit of traction a little
bit of Hope a little bit of momentum you
know that oh that that can I can just
breathe for the next month you know just
sometimes that's all you need to give
the energy to keep going and so that was
it for me
and then it gave me even more momentum
and more hope and I got more deals and
more more Partnerships and so
as a result of that anytime I didn't
know what to do I modeled success I
asked hey who has done this thing before
and how can I learn from them I want to
hopefully tell Bill Gates that story
when I meet him and let them know the
impact that he's had on my life
if you feel stuck then what can you do
if you feel stuck in a hole if you have
a dream that you want to chase down that
you feel like you don't have enough
momentum let me give you a couple
strategies that I think can help number
one is find a mentor right model success
you don't have to know the person right
this is where I think a lot of these
Mentor rules break down because
everybody will say find a mentor find a
mentor find a mentor okay but I don't
know anybody I don't know anybody who
knows anybody right I mean I went to my
banker asking for advice because I
thought Banks were supposed to give
entrepreneurs advice and help it's like
how little I knew in certain my company
so Bill Gates became my mentor and he
saved my business even though I have
never met him
look at who has done the thing that you
want to do
and go learn from them
there's there's Clues right success
leaves Clues find the people who have
done that thing that inspire you because
it gives you the hope that it's possible
for you too and it gives you a specific
strategy that you can apply seeing how
Bill Gates started his first business
started Microsoft gave me hope that I
could do it too but it also gave me a
lesson to say okay go find Partnerships
and that's that combination of the Hope
plus the strategy gave me the recipe to
start to build my business so go find
mentors it's why I make all these videos
with so many channels now there's so
much content out there if you love
visual learning like I do then there's a
video every single day across multiple
channels for you to go learn from but if
it's not my channel you prefer books or
podcasts Your Heroes are out there
sharing their wisdom
use it you don't have to go and sit down
and have coffee with them to learn from
them I call them aspirational mentors
they're out there surround yourself with
them learn from them because they can
help transport you from where you are
today to where you want to be okay so
step number one go find mentors step
number two is get community and honestly
this is the biggest mistake that I made
in starting my first business I had two
business partners
who were great out of me I don't know
how I would have kept going without my
two business partners
but we fought too you know when when
you're not making money you start to
disagree over the direction of the
company and I didn't feel like I had
anybody I could talk to about
the business and what I should be doing
I had no Community my parents were
always willing to listen but I was you
know embarrassed to keep going to them
and I definitely didn't want to talk to
my friends because I turned down the
jobs that they wanted to do this
business and I say to myself that's
really just fear and insecurity talking
I probably could have gone to them and
they would have been super supportive
and fine and helpful and listen if
they're not dump them and get new
friends but I was I was too afraid to do
it and I see now in my movement makers
for example it's my monthly membership
the value of people being connected to
each other so movement makers when they
join they're learning from me awesome
but they also get to connect with other
people who are doing something similar
who are on their mission their Journey
so you feel like you're not going
through this thing alone you need to
find Community whether it's movement
makers or your friends or other online
communities don't go through this alone
get a community of people who are
like-minded who you can pour into right
it's not a one-way Street you can point
to them support them encourage them and
when you feel like your cup is empty
other people will pour into you in a
loving way telling you that you can't do
it giving you hope giving you optimism
giving you strategies giving you a hug
to help you get back up on your feet so
you can go chase down your mission so
number one is get some mentors number
two is get some community
and then number three
is create a calendar for consistency one
of the biggest problems that
entrepreneurs have is you start and you
stop and you start and you stop and you
start and you stop and you start and you
stop and you're motivated and high and
energetic and amazing I'm gonna go do
this thing
and then it doesn't work out or then you
lose the the motivation or you feel
frustrated or you get scared again or
that little inner critic starts taking
over and you don't follow through on the
action
it's important that you create a
calendar for Success if it's not in your
calendar it's not going to happen so
what are the objectives that you have
for your business for your relationships
for your for your health for your goals
like what's the life that you want
to get the success that you're after
comes down to the habits that you're
executing on and the habits should be in
your calendar so you can't say you want
to go build the successful business or
if I was going to take Bill Gates's
partnership strategy
I need to put in my calendar
I'm going to spend this amount of time
every day or every week working on
Partnerships I need to identify who my
potential partners are I need to reach
out to those Partners I need to follow
up with the partners right that is
scheduled time in my calendar every week
to make sure that I actually go off and
accomplish it because you might feel
motivated today and you might do some
action today awesome that's not enough
it's the consistency in the follow
through where you really start to win
and achieve your goals
you've got a big dream inside you that's
why you're here why are you watching
these videos you got a dream you want to
be somewhere else you want to be you
want to be a better you you want to
contribute to others you want to feel
like you matter like today matters like
what you're going to do and create is
gonna matter to people you've got that
dream inside you not just for yourself
but for the impact that you want to
create
but it doesn't happen
until you actually start to create
to model the success
to get your community and to create that
calendar around the actions that you
need to be doing the habits daily you do
that and we start to move from the land
of dreams and hopes and wants and move
into the land of
achieving
reality
impact
purpose
you've got that you're capable now let's
see you do it
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
speaking of this idea of distribution
and and free-flowing we're seeing the
rise of gig economy freelance work uh
apps like uber that are having big
effects in the world and including
effects on labor and how work Works any
thoughts on what this might mean moving
into the future and freelance economy
well the a key element is education and
it is interesting
in a certain way how
now that we have all you know courses
about almost everything you still have
to pay a little bit for The Learning
Company to get the very best but in math
and science even the free stuff is
extremely good uh that's out there and
yet you know and for early level math we
have Khan Academy and lots of things
that has had a truly modest effect on
act actual skill levels and so the
motivational aspects
um you know why do you learn many people
learn just to get a degree because that
uh is how you get a job but how do you
make things interesting
that's kind of an unsolved problem so I
do view uh you know retraining and
education that in order to deal with the
dynamism of this uh fast-paced
Innovation that you also want to make
equivalent breakthroughs not just in
automating things but improving
education and if you could have one wish
to improve one thing in an economy uh
you know education is kind of the master
switch of your capability there's a few
things like energy instability and trust
that are in part two but education would
be uh right up there and yet you know if
I say to you oh the best math teacher
lived 50 years ago he's better than any
math teacher since then you couldn't
disprove that that was right that is our
understanding of how you draw kids in
and how you understand their
misconceptions is it's it's very ad hoc
the average math teacher today is
probably about the same uh as 20 years
ago and yet you know if we can do agents
you know we're talking about the general
issue of being able to read and and form
knowledge the idea being as good as
one-on-one math tutor and seeing what
types of conceptual mistakes people make
and even more importantly understanding
how you motivate them uh to you know
that you keep it at the right level or
you create the right uh sort of problem
domain that they might be interested in
or you know some sort of contest or draw
a social aspect into it that
motivational piece is where you see most
of the variants it's not domain
knowledge uh that uh and it makes
difference as we see because that it's
online and yet uh uh we don't see much
change so I am enthused about that
whether that means that your learning
will be more episodic and you continue
to do it in adulthood you know that
would be ideal uh so that even if the
job market is switching your uh uh
qualified you really have to believe the
internet's going to be mainstream a lot
of people are going to get out there and
use it and that they're going to be
willing to pay for some content is that
the operating idea that you have
well each of these businesses is an
entrepreneurial business uh the
overreaching theme is that yes I believe
in the internet I believe it'll get
increasingly popular and we're doing
some neat new things to take advantage
of that is you've got a lot of cash on
hand yes right all right it puts you in
an invisible position you can experiment
with a lot of entrepreneurial ideas and
see what sticks and what flies
well we're in business to make money and
but the other thing is providing such a
cash flow for you
well it all belongs to the shareholders
we're not dilettos we are business
people and it is true that if you find
an idea that requires three or four
years of improvement and patience I'm
really sticking with it uh that we're
very good at that take Windows which we
BET our company on everybody who doubted
that would succeed IBM did not support
us in that uh it took longer than we
expected uh over four years before
finally graphical interface got popular
and now people take it for granted it's
part of every personal computer and you
just you just expect it to be there that
was one of the grand successes of the
company you went to Harvard and you
dropped out have you ever thought how
your life could be better off if you had
gotten your Harvard degree
well I I'm a weird Dropout because I
take college courses all the time I love
uh Learning Company courses and and
things so I love being a student and
there were smart people around and you
know they fed you and they gave you
these nice grades that made you feel
smart uh so I I feel it was unfortunate
uh that I didn't get to stay there but I
don't think I missed any knowledge
because you know whatever I needed to
learn I would I was still in a a
learning mode if you ask people across
the United States is the future going to
be better than the past most say no
my kids will be worse off than I am
they think Innovation won't make the
world better for them or their children
so who's right
the people who say Innovation will
create new possibilities and make the
word world better
or the people who see a trend toward
inequality and a decline in opportunity
and don't think Innovation will change
that
the pessimists are wrong in my view
but they're not crazy
if Innovation is purely Market driven
and we don't focus on the big inequities
then we could have amazing advances and
inventions that leave the world even
more divided
we won't improve Public Schools we won't
cure malaria
we won't end poverty
we won't develop the Innovations poor
Farmers need to grow food in a changing
climate
if our optimism doesn't address the
problems that affect so many of our
fellow human beings then our optimism
needs more empathy
if empathy channels are optimism we will
see the poverty and the disease and the
poor schools we will answer with our
Innovations and we will surprise the
pessimists
over the next Generation you Stanford
graduates will lead a new wave of
innovation
which problems will you decide to solve
if your world is wide you can create the
future we all want
if your world is narrow
you may create the future the pessimist
fear
I started learning in suedo that if
we're going to make our optimism matter
to everyone and Empower people
everywhere we have to see the lives of
those most in need
if we have optimism without empathy then
it doesn't matter how much we Master the
secrets of science we're not really
solving problems we're just working on
puzzles
I think most of you have a broader world
view than I had at your age
you can do better at this than I did
if you put your hearts and Minds to it
you can surprise the pessimists
we're eager to see it the idea that
computers were going to be a change
agent you know I was lucky enough to
meet Paul Allen and early on we
brainstormed about this idea of the Chip
and the chip changed the rules I mean
most things don't get a million times
better not you know engine efficiency or
uh you know most things have uh
theoretical minimums computation is
something that we're not even close to
the theoretical minimum yet we've
improved so much so seeing that that was
going to come and weirdly that most
people didn't see that was going to come
so you know even people at IBM were
still thinking in terms of big computers
you know now all the the uh software and
service driven companies are worth even
more than IBM when I was growing up IBM
was the monolith and it was always okay
are we going to beat him are we going to
join them those bastards actually they
were very nice people but we always
thought of them uh and they they sort of
stood for these big computers that only
big companies and governments could get
the benefit for so actually we played
off of that to have this power to the
people personal Computing type thing of
course now we're a big company uh and
somebody can play off of us the idea
that a young person could start a
company here is a super nice thing
because although people at first are
skeptical as soon as they realize their
normal model of what I knew and what I
could do that I didn't fit that normal
wall model then they assumed I knew way
more than I did and I could solve all
sorts of problems I had no clue uh you
know how to solve but you know it was
nice uh that people were kind of a Gog
that we had built this company and done
these things
from a young age I think the culture of
America that you know almost the
American dream type success story is a
fairly special time because computers
when I was young were super expensive
and my friend Paul Allen and I actually
snuck into places at the University of
Washington where they had computers that
weren't being used at night and so we
were fascinated by what the computer
could do but very few people were
getting exposure we had to go out of our
way and we were lucky that we did it all
and so then when the idea of moving the
computer on to a chip that Intel would
make and it would make the computer
literally millions of times cheaper than
the ones we were using so both more
powerful and available to people on a
personal level then the idea of okay it
would be very different the software you
needed the way the industry would work
we were super lucky to uh
be there when that was happening so what
did your family think did they say
there's something wrong with this young
man he wants to just do computers they
knew I was obsessed with computers that
I would skip Athletics that I'd go in
overnight that I'd you know leave the
house sometimes when they prefer I
wouldn't go work at night on these
things and so I was kind of considered a
little strange
and the big moment was when I said
instead of going to part of my senior
year
that I wanted to go work for company
writing software so they were great
about allowing that to be my hobby you
want to have impact uh usually
delegation is important although you
know individual contributors in terms of
the denting a drug or a new approach to
things
that's phenomenal so when Microsoft
first got started I wrote most the code
and everybody else's code I read and
kind of rewrote uh and that got us up to
10 people and then I had to say to
myself okay we're going to ship code
that I didn't edit uh and that was hard
for me uh but you know I kind of got
over that then I still said okay I'm
going to interview everyone and I'm
going to at least look at samples of
their code well that got us up to about
40 people and that was at a point where
I had sold way more software than we
could write uh because everybody was so
impressed and I thought well I need to
keep enough collect enough money to you
know keep hiring all these people but uh
the demand was so high that you know we
were actually falling behind that's when
I hired Steve and Steve figured out a uh
how to control what promises I made to
people and B how to hire lots of people
and good really good people and create
organizations and teams so I delegated
to Steve that and he was constantly
saying to me okay we're going to hire
programmers that you've never met and
I'd say no we're not and then he would
show me numerically that the constraint
wasn't going to work uh you know so uh
then I said okay then I would you know
know all the managers of the people and
so over time uh and of course you know I
could say the quality per person was
falling monotonically
uh uh
according to me uh but in a large
problems uh if you want to you know
write the most popular office
productivity software that one person
absolutely can't do that you can write
pretty code so everyone has to decide
what scale of organization they want to
work in eventually you know my role was
very much as a leader and a reviewer of
managers but the top people and I've
hired some super experienced people uh I
would make sure they were pursuing a
common vision and they were well
coordinated but in terms of a lot of
management stuff they were way better
than I was now I had to have the
framework to know what mix of skills
that we needed and you know when they
were working well enough together but a
lot of uh you know my value Adam was
picking
say to do Graphics user on her face or
to do an integrated office uh type thing
or to go Global and not use agents to
have Microsoft be present all over the
world and so yeah picking what you're
good at and how you find the other
people uh to fill in those things that's
super important and most Founders don't
aren't able to scale that up and kind of
give up the Hands-On things that they
used to get a lot of uh pleasure and
comfort from you were here with your
daughter who is 21 right and you were 21
when you became a billionaire is that
right almost yeah all right so around
that age you were like the youngest
person to become a billionaire is that
right yeah yeah in terms of my own
earning it on my own yeah right okay so
which is the most important thing yeah
so did you when you were a kid did you
did you care about money or you just
cared about technology and that's it
just happened
uh mostly I love software uh I do
remember at the private school I went to
there were other kids whose families
were better off like they had a Porsche
or something but it wasn't that that big
of a deal my thing was that I just love
doing software I loved hiring people and
I was stunned when it ended up being so
valuable really yeah you did it
surprised you yeah because I always had
to be careful that we wouldn't hired too
many people I was always worried because
I was people who worked for me were
older to me and they had kids and I
always thought what if we don't get paid
will I be able to meet the payroll so I
was always very conservative about the
finances and then when we did go uh
public uh what was I uh 30 by then uh
then I was kind of stunned at what it
multiplied out to my question to you is
if you suddenly found yourself to be uh
say a sophomore in college at Harvard
what do you think you would uh study and
how do you think you'd spend your time
engaging activities
well the thing that you're likely to be
world class at is whatever you obsessed
over from say age 12 to 18.
you know in my case it was writing
software
uh where I would think I was good and
then I would meet somebody who would
tell me I wasn't and I would look at
their code and I went through four sort
of comeuppances of oh that's what a
really good programmer looks like and
part of the reason I worshiped digital
equipment was eventually it was a couple
of their very best programmers who came
and shared with me how they thought
about it how they did things and I had
studied their code and uh and that and
there were several people who were so
key to my doing that so today I would go
into you know software which today that
means going into artificial intelligence
uh you know computers still can't read
they they cannot take a book of
information and say pass an AP test on
that book and that's a solvable problem
but it's a knowledge representation
problem and you know I've always wanted
to solve that problem uh I'm jealous
that maybe one of you gets to work on
that I I'm you know unlikely to go back
and be Hands-On in that in that way but
it's the juiciest problem ever I've
thought about it for a long time uh so I
would go into AI I think
you know you can over worship and
mythologize the idea of working
extremely hard for my particular makeup
I mean it really is true that I didn't
believe in weekends I didn't believe in
vacations I mean you know I knew
everybody's license plate so I could
tell you over the last month when their
car had come and gone from the parking
lot is so I don't recommend it a I don't
think most people would enjoy it uh once
I got into my 30s I could hardly even
imagine how I had done that uh because
by then some natural behavior kicked in
and I loved weekends and uh you know my
girlfriend liked vacations and that
turned out to be kind of a neat thing uh
now I take lots of vacations my 20 year
old self is so disgusted with my uh
current uh uh self you know I I was sure
I would never do any riding coach you
know now I have a plane so it's it's
very much counter Revelations and taking
place at high speed but yes it is nice
if during those first several years
if you have a team that's chosen to be
pretty maniacal about the company and
how far that goes you should have a
mutual understanding see or not uh one
person expecting one thing another
person expecting another thing
and you'll have individuals who who have
you know health or relatives or things
that are distracted but yes I have a
fairly hardcore View
that there should be a very large uh
sacrifice made during those
those early years the quality that uh
has helped me in lots of things
is a kind of measurement scientific
framework where I go in and say did
anybody handle this well what are the
very best practices do we have numbers
on that and let's get everybody
measuring what they're doing and so they
can strive to match what that the best
achievement is for us often that's
something like getting the vaccines how
tall the children throughout
our history we wake every day knowing
that in the business of Technology you
have to think about what are you missing
what is the research or customer
feedback that you should be paying more
attention to and how do you keep that
pace of innovation very very high how do
you make sure you're hiring the very
best people and that kind of focus is
has helped drive us forward through all
the Milestones the company has had
certainly the internet is is a great
example of that we had to tear up our
our plans and and step back and say well
how do we how do we really embrace all
that's good about the internet and
recognize some of the shortcomings and
make sure we're leading the way in uh
reducing what what has held people away
from the internet if you were 20 years
old today and you wanted to start a new
company drop out of Harvard what company
or what area would you want to start it
in well this is a a great time to be
doing Innovation because the tools of
innovation are so much better there are
lots of things in biology that are very
interesting uh there are lots of things
in energy that are interesting given my
background I would start an AI company
that uh whose goal would be to teach
computers how to read so that they can
absorb and understand all the written
knowledge of the world that's an area
where AI has yet to make progress and it
will be quite profound when we achieve
that goal your early days you described
yourself as a nightmare boss is it your
words not mine um was your worth at work
ethic just very different to everybody
else's I was fanatical uh in my 20s
helping Microsoft lead the way in
software was the only thing that I
really focused on so you know I worked
weekends I didn't believe in vacation
and so I I really pushed people to work
hard uh and I was still learning how to
manage people particularly the different
skill sets the sales people the
accounting people we got to know each
other we would uh be traveling around
Lagos where the traffic gives you lots
of time to sit and talk uh sometimes and
you know I'd be showing the leak of my
charts about hey sokoto has a pretty low
vaccination rate uh you know and Kano
needs to do this and and aliko he really
knows people he has relationships he's
willing to reach out to people so he'd
say hey let's call the governor you know
and we'll talk to him about this and
sure enough you know next thing you know
we've got the governor of sakota on the
phone we're talking about uh this and so
this ability now to reach out to draw on
the the broad relationships uh the
alicos developed and you know I'm pretty
shy about calling people I just want to
mail them my chart
but in fact uh what's come out of that
is that uh aliko and I do a video
conference call with six of the
governors in the northern states where
uh twice a year we look at uh vaccine
coverage in our is the supply chain
working are the workers showing up or
the health care posts in the right
locations
and it's a big challenge but uh really
drawing on alico's communication skills
and the fact that he's not afraid to
call anyone everybody wants to talk to
him uh it's been phenomenal I get to
when I you know say okay we're going to
build a TB drug team we're going to
build the TB vaccine team we're going to
build them uh you know kill all the
mosquitoes in the world Gene Drive
crispr team
I get to in terms of how we fund that
organize it how many locations do we
wait till they have this result before
we scale it up I get to use the same
uh
or 80 percent the same uh type of
thinking that I exercised in terms of
okay let's go do windows let's go do
excel uh so it's backing Engineers it's
getting a sense of the team you know
what needs to be added to that team or
the IQs on the team adding up uh as
opposed to subtracting from each other
and it's very comfortable because the
the most intense period of Microsoft was
where these teams were about size 30 and
for our diseases you know typhoid
rotavirus there's a lot of diseases uh
that hopefully you'll never hear of
again uh most of which don't exist here
in the U.S but uh
so it is very very similar it takes a
decade generally from start to finish
the AIDS vaccine actually we're on year
14 and uh it'll probably be another
eight to ten years before that one is
completely done so some take as long as
as 20 years because there's many dead
ends and you have kind of a portfolio of
approaches but yes I feel like my
working with governments hiring smart
people uh managing teams it did prepare
me well for this very operational uh
organization that's a lot like a
business except that we're our profit is
live saved as opposed to a monetary
measures it's great that people are
worried about the problems uh because
they require action you know even take
inequity globally and Equity is down
that is the poor countries are getting
richer uh faster than the Richer
countries are getting richer right the
bulk of humanity lives in middle-income
countries today if you go back 50 years
there were very very few middle income
countries there's pretty bimodal where
you had Indian China Africa were poor
and then Europe U.S Japan starting to be
fairly well off and not much in the
middle but today uh China's at the high
end of middle income India's at the low
on the middle income Brazil Indonesia
it's a it's a phenomenal story and the
ability of science to solve problems uh
you know clearly in the case of heart
disease and cancer make a lot of
progress some of the more chronic
diseases like depression diabetes I'm
optimistic even obesity uh you know
we're gaining some fundamental
understandings of the microbiome and the
signaling mechanisms involved in these
things so yes I am optimistic it does
bother me that that most people aren't
optimistic and you know so one of us is
wrong one of us is right most people
over the last 200 years or so whoever
they the wealthiest person in the world
was didn't usually work that hard when
they got to be 60 or so they kind of
took life easy you seem to be working
pretty hard what motivates you to still
work so hard
well I love my work the work of the
foundation is super interesting I get to
meet with the scientists I get to go out
in the field I do think your habits are
sort of set in your 20s and 30s
and by my standards of the 20s you know
I didn't believe in weekends back then
uh not to mention Vacations so I'm you
know fairly lazy compared to myself in
my 20s where I was a true uh fanatic uh
you know all I believed in was working
on software
night and day and and for my 20s that
was perfect I didn't have a wife or
family uh at all and my rule was very
Hands-On roll in the early days
um you know you were just a College
Dropout you were very young looking did
you get taken seriously by businessmen
who are much older for some people that
youth uh and geekiness uh was like Hey
should we trust them you know that's so
weird we've never seen something like
that before so yes we had to fight for
acceptance I couldn't rent cars uh so I
had to take cabs around because I was
too young and you know probably some
people were a little tough but then as
as we got a little bit of success people
were fascinated by this deep belief we
had in in software we think that
progress can actually accelerate the
last 50 last 15 years have been
wonderful but the next 15 we can do more
uh and some people worry that when you
you talk about progress that it'll uh
reduce people's commitment to make
things better they think when you talk
about progress that it shows you're
naive and that maybe you don't realize
uh all those things that are left to be
done and how horrific they are uh and
you know so sometimes that purely that
negative side of the story gets told but
you lose something very important uh if
you only look at it that way you lose
the optimism about what's possible and
you lose the information where you look
at the places that have done better than
others and you understand what is it
about delivery Innovation Partnerships
caring what has come together
uh for the very best progress and then
spread that to the other places that's
what will help us Thrive at full speed
urgency that I felt that if we didn't
get Microsoft going right away that
someone he would do a great job building
the software company we won't have a
chance that probably ended up not being
true that I could have waited two or
three years and the opportunity to do
Microsoft still would be there but
anyway I felt a sense of urgency uh and
you know it's not like
you know I still get to take courses and
learn things
um today you know things like The
Learning Company and there's all sorts
of great books so it's not like I've
missed some part of my education right
when you dropped out your father and
mother said are you sure you know what
you want to do if one of your children
dropped out of college to start a
company what would you say
well I'd have to say yes but uh the
dropping out is not an irrevocable
decision uh you know if you try and
start a company it doesn't go well they
always let you go back I feel like you
always seem to swing for the fences in
general it's just sort of a new way of
framing it but I have to ask if you are
swinging for the fences what if you miss
well hopefully uh you get more than one
swing
either at the same problem like you know
multiple malaria vaccine constructs so
that you know if you have two or three
the combined chance of success is much
higher or that you're working in
multiple areas not just one area right
you know in climate for example
I have a company that's uh trying to
make a nuclear reactor that would be
very cheap and that would have safety so
that the public would be very accepting
of it now you know even I realize that's
high risk you know less than 50 percent
chance all that comes together and yet
uh if it did and the only reason I'm
involved is it would really help with
climate knowing that you're doing all
this work but someone in my position I'm
not a philanthropist I don't necessarily
have the means how does someone like me
or someone watching this help in the
best way they can
well I wish more people could actually
get to these countries you know uh join
the Peace Corps spend time even uh just
spending a few weeks there and see how
great the needs are and see the progress
a lot of uh you know volunteer work
in the United States builds that sense
of okay we care about other humans even
you know beyond our own uh family group
even people who have very different
experiences so you know at a young age a
little bit of giving money away uh you
know to form that habit and picking
which things you really want to give to
including lots of things here in the US
and getting involved with volunteer time
those are the people uh who I think will
help kind of bring the world together
and you know avoid uh just this
divisiveness
that is is my greatest concern
historically the newspapers or the the
media
we're very responsible about not letting
uh untruths about vaccine safety get out
there now it's you know you don't want
to get rid of the good thing which is
that anybody can publish the barriers to
entry the diversity of voices is so
phenomenal compared to to traditional
publishing right I feel like and you
have a bit of a YouTube presence so
you're able to share information about
things uh through social media it's kind
of a social media age so I feel like
that ideally helps your cause more than
it hurts it yeah my audience probably
isn't uh deep with the vaccine doubters
yeah you know I in a creative way
uh trying to get positive messages to uh
be interesting and we have work to do on
that you know I would have thought
using experts and scientific knowledge
that the all the internet would just
make it so much easier to learn about
things uh and yet in some ways uh you
know people aren't seeking out complex
information particularly if it disagrees
uh with some preconceived notion that
they have so you know how can social
media
get out there and be a little bit of a
uh Force for Education particularly on
climate where without a consensus
we won't do the the hard things that
will uh save things for the Next
Generation when you were starting
Microsoft there were a lot of other
software companies and you were not
number one at the beginning I think
there were mothers who were a little bit
further ahead what was it that enabled
you to beat everybody else up in the
software business was it Bill Gates was
it something else what was the unique
factor that made you the most successful
yeah we were actually the first and but
there were companies uh and they were
all kind of single product companies
who got ahead of us uh in terms of sales
you know buy uh
about 1991 uh we we did become the
largest uh of all of them we were an
engineering company we were about how
you hire smart people and how you use
tools to develop software broadly
we were Global and we weren't about a
single product so like for example word
perfect was a word processor somebody
might remember
they did so well with that product that
their gross sales rivaled ours when we
were doing a broad set of products as
soon as Graphics interface caught on
which was Windows that became mainstream
in 1995. we became far larger than the
other software companies now
subsequently uh you know Google Apple
uh Amazon have become uh you know also
extremely successful but in the 90s we
were the strongest uh okay by far the
idea that you could get people to to
decide to support this foreign aid thing
which is a big deal uh
uh for our foundation from a numeric
point of view we're still pushing that a
little bit but honestly the story of the
one child
you know if you say to an audience
here's the picture of this child shall
we save this child they're more engaged
than if you said hey let's save a
million children you know so there's
definitely a sort of you know 10 to the
sixth problem uh here somewhere uh yeah
that humans are not wired uh
to be to do that on a numeric basis
um and so you know that's why we have
people like Bono and and many others who
come from a more storytelling world and
then they let me throw a few charts and
numbers in just uh because I think uh
that that should should be there once
your heart tells you what direction to
go in to prove that this is a a very
affordable not you know not a big deal
well-managed path to to be on and
Microsoft my early partner was Paul
Allen and then Steve Ballmer uh was my
partner now Melinda's uh you know even a
totally equal partner in all the
foundation work we're doing so she she
and I run it together it was so
fascinating I mean the relationships
we're building learning all this new
stuff to have somebody to brainstorm
with about it uh you know made it a lot
more fun you know things like writing
letters together giving speeches
together we had to learn how to bring
out the best of the both of us in in
doing those things but yeah it was
always you know clear we wanted to do it
together let's say you're interviewing
for a junior engineer position at
Microsoft sitting in a boardroom or on
video call in 2020 why should we hire
you you should look at the code that
I've written you know I'm kind of crazy
I write software programs Way Beyond any
classes that I've taken and think I've
gotten better over time so take a look
at how ambitious I'd been there I do
think I can work well with people I
might criticize their code a little
harshly but overall I like to be on a
team I like ambitious goals I like
thinking through how we can anticipate
the future software is cool and I want
to be involved you have any regrets in
your life you seem to have a life that
many people would love to live you've
got a happy family great marriage
Foundation business success is there
anything can you make us feel good by
saying you've done something that didn't
work out or just make us because all of
us feel bad because we look at you and
we can't do what you've done so tell us
something that's bad that you've done
honor you'd feel inadequate about
something there must be something no I
am super lucky uh you know they marrying
Melinda
uh the experience that Microsoft uh that
although it had its ups and downs was uh
phenomenal uh the work of the foundation
and
no regrets about anything I wouldn't try
and go back and change anything I mean
for example the antitrust lawsuit
against Microsoft you know was bad for
the company it created a lot of
distraction we would have done a lot of
things including the mobile operating
system better if it hadn't been for that
but in a way it was a lesson for me uh
and you know so it and it probably
accelerated my requirement uh by five or
six years which overall for me probably
was a a good thing
um you know I don't think it was a
principled right set of activities but
that's another story if you want to
learn computer science just you know
knuth wrote the book buy it okay uh you
know read it and do the problems for if
you really think you know this thing if
you want to learn physics Feynman wrote
the book uh just read the damn book it's
all there so that when we put stuff
online it we don't have anything in
online physics that's any better than
feynman's book honest honestly now it's
a little easier to learn uh you know the
guy makes jokes every 20 minutes or at
least tries to uh and he does more demos
and things so learning is a weird social
phenomena and so you know our foundation
our big problem is that the group that
does the worst with online learning are
low-income students because their notion
of why am I learning their sense of
self-confidence the ability to figure
out oh I just got stuck because you know
two minuses cancel out and I I never saw
that notation before they just hit dead
ends all the time that if you're sitting
in your dormant Stanford you know
somebody walks down and helps you get
through it as usual if you have you know
negative consequences for mistakes it
kind of discourages that completing the
loop type system there there are a few
cases like in in civil aviation where
the willingness to look at mistakes and
apply massive resources like we're
seeing today to say okay what went wrong
here it really is pretty mind-blowing I
like to look at numbers a lot and so
when I look at the numbers I'm just
amazed whether it's the quality of the
inner city education the Dropout rates
Oprah did a thing where she had kids
from an inner city school go look at the
suburban school and vice versa and they
were just stunned at the building and
everything was so completely different
so I think you know even for me I have
to go you know whether it's the inner
city in America talking to people who
live there or outside the US we have
this same thing you know the situation
in Africa you know it's overwhelmingly a
black population is so much worse than
people are probably aware of and so
Hands-On visits whether it's to the
schools or the clinics I think that is
necessary to hear the voices of people
who've been hurt and then you know
there's a lot of good movies now there's
a lot of good books I was just reading
the new Jim Crow which is pretty
eloquent and forceful about the justice
system and the role that it plays in
perpetuating bad conditions and you know
it takes a lot to try and put yourself
having empathy for other people so we
all have to push harder on this today
people come to you all the time for
money I assume everywhere you go people
say by the way I have this thing you
should invest in but I have a couple
myself I'll mention later no no a couple
things you should invest in or things
you should give money to so how do you
resist it you have some person who says
no for you or how do you do that let
many people uh many people say no well
once you picked what you care about if
somebody has something that can make a
difference in global Health we're super
interested in you know we have a staff
of 1500 people and if it's to do with
global Health some of those people will
come out and talk through with you
whatever you're in Innovation is and how
we can partner with you on that you know
so that's clearly in our area if it is
something that can substantially improve
K-12 education then we're going to be
very interested in it if people are
asking outside of those things then you
know fortunately you can say no because
focus is is key to philanthropy the
digital Revolution internet social media
all of that in certain respects it's
made it easier for us to see what's
going on medical researchers are
publishing articles every day and all
over the world people can immediately
see what the new thinking is there
tracking the disease statistics I click
on the John Hopkins website every
morning and see okay which countries are
having a tough time with cases or or
deaths thank God for the internet work
at home you know our ability to connect
up with each other is driven by that but
it also has meant that a lot of very
surprisingly interesting conspiracy
theories that are fall sadly they spread
a lot faster than the truth you know so
the idea that did somebody intentionally
cause this thing completely false even
in some cases accusing me of having some
connection that can be dangerous because
it means you know your willingness to
believe is the vaccine something I
should take should I wear masks you know
if you go for these simple but wrong
theories getting people to work together
and protect each other so we can get out
of this as soon as possible that's
really at risk you raised the question
of how should the government deal with
that it's very difficult ideally
citizens are just well informed and they
know which Publications are very careful
about what they say and we don't have to
engage in censorship but so much of the
almost crazy false information is out
there that looking at the companies like
Facebook and saying okay what is their
role in that you know when somebody says
masks don't work which is wrong or they
say just take
hydroxychloroquine and you'll be totally
safe what is their responsibility for
catching those things particularly when
they get out to large numbers that is
being debated and you know I think we'll
come out of this with those companies
feeling a stronger sense of
responsibility and actually
understanding having the public debate
about uh how they need to help here
there's no doubt that the antitrust
lawsuit was bad for Microsoft and it it
we would have been more focused on
creating the uh phone operating system
and so instead of using Android today
you would be using Windows mobile if it
hadn't been for the under trust case uh
oh we were so close we we you know I was
just too distracted I screwed that up uh
because of the distraction and you know
we were just three months too late with
the release that Motorola would have
used on a phone uh so yes uh it's a
winner take all game that is for sure
that you know now nobody here has ever
heard of Windows mobile but oh well and
I wouldn't uh
that's a few hundred billion here or
there uh
I wouldn't have retired as soon and that
one is less you know I am disappointed
that Windows mobile didn't succeed but
in terms of uh my own life you know even
though it was a very painful thing
because I got very personally involved
in the defense of the company the fact
that I retired earlier probably net was
good for me because I got down the
learning curve on the foundation I got
to partner with Melinda in the early
days of the foundation and you know I
don't have a life where I'm allowed to
complain uh because basically you know
only 99 percent of things have worked
out very very well I'm very lucky that
my foundation work the part-time work I
do for Microsoft I see that extending
you know for decades into the future and
having an understanding of innovation uh
you know I think shaping innovation in
many of these areas
there is a unique role that I can I can
help play today the greatest pleasure of
your life is when you're doing what is
it other than being interviewed by me or
something like that what are the great
greatest pleasure of your life
uh you know time with kids time with
Scientists uh time when I'm reading and
things are making sense
um
you know going out and seeing the impact
of the foundation's work
uh meeting with Scientists who think we
can make breakthroughs to help solve
climate uh you know these are super
interesting problems and you know having
a broad set of system thinking applied
to these problems is going to be
necessary to orchestrate the resources
and policies behind them so you know I
love I love my work how would you define
your strengths and your weaknesses how
you can you know incorporate those into
a team kind of aspect well I'm not
somebody who knows a lot about marketing
you know I wouldn't enjoy being a
Salesman for a position where you're
actually creating the products and
thinking through what those features
should be I'm fascinated by that I
followed the history of the industry
read about the mistakes that have been
made so product definition product
creation very strong if you have a team
that understands the customers the sales
the marketing I'm not going to bring
that but I I would enjoy working with
them they
Al and I
had loved working on software since we
were lucky enough to be exposed
literally I was 13 in eighth grade when
this time sharing terminal came in and
we just did it day and night and you
know got better and we could see that
the magic of software combined with this
miracle of the microprocessor subject to
Moore's Law exponential Improvement that
that was a magic combination and we we'd
look around and say hey how come
everybody's not
saying this is amazing I mean we're
going to Dethrone IBM and uh you know
why doesn't digital equipment get it why
is the guy runs it this is a company
that's long gone uh but dominate many
computers at the time why isn't that guy
up there saying it's it's wrong we know
it's right and so the key event for us
was it was a very cool Boston winner
and a kid computer came out on uh this
popular Electronics magazine and we said
oh damn this is happening without us I
mean here we are uh doing nothing and so
we called the company up and said you
know hey we're ready uh and then we
called them back we actually did the
work and then we called them back and
said how do you make the stuff go in and
out of the computer the i o and they
said well that's interesting nobody else
has ever asked that you must really be
doing something so that was anyway our
very first customer and so we grabbed on
to it to be the very first and we were
the first to say there should be a
software industry and and come and do it
in a sense it was one of the lower risk
things I've ever done in my life because
you know I could have always gone back I
decided to to focus more on giving away
than than making money
and so I've uh gotten a chance to travel
the world be out in Africa and Asia
quite a bit and see the needs that are
out there and now our foundation is very
focused on global Health uh focused on
agriculture because the majority of the
the very poor in the world are farmers
who have very small plots of land so any
increase in productivity or certainty of
their crop coming in can make huge
difference for them
and you might think of a career in
software you know selling to people who
can afford personal computers and now
the career the foundation has been very
different and certainly they're
different in the sense that now it's
about vaccines now a lot it's it's with
various governments the donor
governments the governments in import
countries but at its core it's really
basically the same thing which is uh
finding innovators people who've got
breakthrough ideas be willing to back
them understand what they're working on
a measure what they're coming up with
I'll try and make sure that when it's
delivered it really has the impact it's
supposed to be and getting into a
feedback loop driven by a very precise
measurement we felt a little banned I I
certainly I did about leaving the
university
when uh I thought very interesting work
on artificial intelligence was really on
the verge of taking place and
symbolically proving programs were
correct ironically now you know it's
taken a long time the rate of progress
which is hard to make numeric in both
those areas has been quite modest I mean
we haven't come backwards or anything
but AI
is turned out to be a tougher problem
which is is fascinating and now there
there are some interesting advances and
likewise symbolic
type things there are some now advances
so we thought we'd Miss uh being more at
the center of those now through at least
funding Microsoft research we get to to
have some level of involvement in that
one on Paul's ideas was to build a 360
Emulator that was the dominant Mainframe
of the time use bit slice uh
architecture to just you know blow away
the pricing on
Mainframe Computing but we decided that
was kind of boring uh compared to
personal Computing a company came along
about five years later two pi and did it
they didn't do the software piece right
that's why they failed uh because we
still think it was a good idea but we
didn't have anything even close to hey
let's build the computer that we want to
use that we want to have as a tool for
our own uh messing around and
communication and creativity that that
kind of got at the center of our
thinking even from the early days when I
was young I had to read the world book
sort of alphabetically uh and it didn't
have any videos you could click on and
it was you know it's weird to learn
things alphabetically it's kind of hard
to create quite the same framework as
you can with all these great online
materials uh and so I think
the empowerment now you know the
opportunity to see what's going on
whether it's in fields of science or in
places that are far away including
else most need it's never been so great
it's a wonderful time to be a student
now software in terms of letting us
simulate things whether it's scientific
phenomena or social phenomena it's
getting better and better and so I think
almost any major that you have nowadays
uh understanding you know what software
how it's going to change those
activities as a key part of of being at
The Cutting Edge when you have a tragedy
like this pandemic there is always the
possibility you're going to narrow your
community that you care about you're
going to think about yourself or your
family not the whole country including
those who've been been somewhat Left
Behind likewise there's a risk looking
at Africa and other developing countries
and saying no we need to help them out
because difficulties there of not enough
food are are really extreme and small
amounts of the budget less than one
percent can help them out likewise you
don't want to just think about the here
and now you also want to think about the
future after all the government failed
Us by not anticipating this pandemic
there were voices like mine and Ted Talk
and other venues that kind of said hey
get ready we don't know when but it's
coming sadly that didn't happen another
thing we trust government to get us
ready for is climate change that's
coming and it won't be as easy as
creating a vaccine to solve it and so
right now terms of people's sympathy
being broad you know being willing to
address other problems even though
they're not here right now I am actually
seeing a lot of positive voices people
saying make sure the recovery is a green
recovery Europe has done a lot on that
and so and actually the dialogue in
politics about you know does climate
change matter is stronger today than
it's ever been so this closing in and
only worrying about the short term I'm
not seeing that of course your audience
which is very young will be the key to
saying let's not just look at this short
term let's start the Investments that
deal with inequities let's start the
Investments that can make sure climate
change doesn't come in and and have even
more tragic results than this pandemic
does young people thinking about
policies getting involved I think I'm
seeing an uptick I hope that's sustained
because they're you know they're the
ones who will really do the Innovative
work part of the thing that drives
computer science forward is is doing
risky things having a long-term time
Horizon and when Microsoft was a small
company we benefited from the fact that
a t and Xerox and other companies had
made investments in research that they'd
reached out and worked with universities
on a broad basis so we felt very lucky
that as we got to a certain level of
success we could start our own research
group and have that research group be in
partnership with popular universities
all over the world doing Advanced
programming programs things that range
from the work on speech recognition all
the way up to Quantum Computing we have
a fairly Serious Program that has a you
know high risk of failure which makes it
fun and interesting on Quantum Computing
and you know even in the best case it's
probably a decade away before that makes
a difference but that's the kind of
thing that when at work can have
incredibly High payoff creating a board
having people like Dave Marquardt there
who wasn't at the company you know and
we were so overwrought about you know
this is right this is wrong we messed
this up that having people have a little
bit of distance uh come in and talk to
us is good you know for the last uh oh
30 years or so
I've gotten to be friends with Warren
Buffett and he he's in Omaha uh he's not
in this Tech world at all you know and
to him it's like hey how could you ever
know which will rise and which will fall
I'm not going to put money uh until
Apple sold at a multiple of 12. then uh
he decided he could put 50 billion into
that
after he asked all his friends hey you
know if the if somebody had a uh iPhone
that was half as expensive would you
switch away you know or is it more like
jewelry where you really want uh to to
have an iPhone and so he decided that
the those profit streams might not be
eliminated anytime soon anyway he
because he's not in this world he has a
a definite
way of looking at things including this
idea of how uh work should be fun he has
made his work so much fun that he works
more hours than I do he works six days a
week at 88 years old and he likes to say
that he skips to work every day he he
doesn't but uh he says that when he was
83 he could still skip but now he's
gotten really he can't do it uh so uh
having somebody like that you know the
toughest thing I went through was this
antitrust lawsuit where you know it
didn't seem uh very predictable uh and
he was a great counsel during all of
that stuff so getting somebody who's in
successful in another domain uh but yet
kind of a business uh type mindset
anyway for me that that was a huge gift
it's important that we build that
feedback system now exactly how you do
that how much you connect that up to the
pay system uh you know we need
experimentation and we can look at these
other countries that have done it there
is a move afoot to do some of this but
whether the investment levels be enough
to make a high quality and whether the
um there'll be kind of high stakes that
overuse the test scores for this stuff
and and will sort of hurt its reputation
it's hard to say at this point but I'd
say it's giving more feedback to
teachers would be the very first thing
that would get us back up to the uh to
being one of the best in the world I do
think that if you want to talk about
software Innovation that at least
listening to the ideas of people who've
been successful in that area isn't such
a bad thing I mean you could you
literally say that we can't talk to
politicians if you really think that
sharing our opinions about say climate
change or malaria or malnutrition or
Charter Schools you know if that's
really bad uh you know this group does
have more free time they have proven
that you know their energetic consult
can solve some things and often they get
into a phase of their life like Steve
scorchman was putting a lot of his
energy and thought into very creative
and I think what will be positively
impactful philanthropy success is always
a bit dangerous uh
you know and you can think that whatever
your success was was because you know
you are magically uh gifted and
understanding things whereas of course
any success particularly a gigantic
success is a huge number of factors
including hard work and understanding
but timing you know other people who
came to work with you other people that
might have done the same thing who
somehow messed up uh in doing it and so
often you'll you'll have too much
confidence about what you understand uh
you know in science uh as Feynman said
the easiest person to fool is yourself
and so you have to force yourself to go
through uh you know again and again and
think through is this the right thing to
be doing you know will this work am I
doing it because it would be exciting if
it succeeded am I really looking at
these factors in fact in polio several
times we had to say to ourselves was it
time to give up uh or really did we we
think there was a prospect of being able
to move forward certainly during the
time I was at Harvard
I wasn't sure what I was going to do uh
the idea that software was this field
that uh
was the opportunity was unbelievable
that became more obvious during the
three-year period I was here but my dad
had been a lawyer I thought of
mathematics you know like doing well in
the Putnam that was the coolest thing
and the computer software I didn't think
those people were as smart as the math
people so it's like well am I going to
go into the easy field uh or this really
hard field but uh anyway math uh was
fantastic when I finally picked and
decided to go go to Microsoft then I got
into a period
from age uh 19 uh to about 40 where I
wasn't able to look at the latest on you
know how tornadoes work or how
mitochondria work I was pretty mono
maniacal
and when I was able to ask Steve this is
the year 2000 C bomber
uh he he mistakenly graduated uh but
then he started at Stan uh
but I was trying to hire him but his
parents told him you're supposed to
graduate which was fine but then he
started at Stanford Business school and
he was in his first year and I thought
oh this is perfect I'll get him to drop
out of Stanford Business School uh so in
a certain sense he is a Dropout uh uh
and he was very keyed to the success of
Microsoft I mean uh he knew a lot of
things but during that period I didn't
get to do much at Harvard you know I
took all these courses because it was
just so amazing that people were
interested in talking about them and uh
I I have to say I never went to a
lecture during reading period or any
anything because the courses that I was
actually signed up for I finally started
to work on those uh so I was in Hillel
the minute would open to the minute it
would close during reading period trying
to catch up on on that other set of
courses so people say I'm a Dropout
which is literally true
but because I like college courses the
online college courses there's a company
called The Learning Company that I buy
tons and tons of their stuff and I do
you know at least four or five courses a
year in a sense I like uh going to
college more than anyone uh so I've sort
of made sure my job certainly post
Microsoft uh that I get to spend my time
meeting with scientists learning new
things you know seeing what the hard
problems are in some cases giving money
to people to take on uh those very very
hard problems if you want another
amazing Bill Gates clip check it out
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there